basé à guyancourt asmodée diffuse ces
jeux de société dans une cinquantaine de
pays à l'entreprise figure parmi les
leaders dans le monde et durant cette
période de confinement elle vient de
lancer print and play daboll dixit ou
encore time line et unlock six de ses
best-sellers sont disponibles
gratuitement une solution pour s'occuper
en famille les cartes de jeu sont
imprimables est similaire à celle que
l'on trouve dans le commerce des vidéos
permettent également de mieux comprendre
les règles
bien que la vente des jeux de société et
explose depuis le 16 mars avec une
progression de plus de 80 % à la
fermeture de nombreux points de vente et
les restrictions des ventes en ligne
rendent difficiles les achats d'autres
titres print and play devrait être
disponible en téléchargement
prochainement
[Musique]